what's up guys welcome to lunch money
on a Tuesday while while she's trying to
get rich the rest of us just trying to
get our lunch money right coming to you
every day at noon issue is because we
don't have our [ __ ] together sometimes
before noon afternoon right at noon or
5:00 p.m. the beautiful and intelligent
plenum Air Nova is here she's got on red
she's violating the dress code it's fine
it's a red kind of day what a red
Tuesday yeah all right let's get into
the first topic bailouts everybody want
to bail out what's going on the bailout
hello this is your you're forgetting
your hole already guys do you see what
I'm dealing with here 500 500 billion
dollar bailout
because of coronavirus has kind of
crushed them everybody want to bail out
the airlines the movie theaters your
local government everybody want to bail
out but just so we're clear the
government asking the government for a
bailout why do I pay taxes let's get
right to the facts let's just get right
to the facts
the government says okay you're a local
or state government here's the deal
we're gonna have to raise revenue so
here's what the things that they do they
say you're gonna pay me taxes you're
gonna pay me parking tickets you're
gonna pay me speeding tickets you're
gonna pay me applications so you can go
build your building you're gonna pay me
for you want to buy a gun or you want a
hunting license we're gonna pull on all
this revenue the main part of it is from
taxes okay but now when I run out of
money I don't go bankrupt I just go to
the government we just rent more they
need your money I can't print any they
need your money in normal times but
right now it's Korona times and
everything is crazy in trouble then you
know a lot of government agencies aren't
even open couldn't even get a miracle if
they if the government can't run
something appropriately then it should
be privatized
would you rather them ask you this would
you rather to have a public inefficient
organization running something or a
pride
inefficient capitalistic approach to
running something I will say the New
York DMV was pretty great it was great
do you think a private company could do
better than the DMV probably but that's
you know I don't know but my poll here's
my point is we got the government's
asking the government to bail them out
but this is absurd right hey governor go
figure this [ __ ] out stop asking people
to print more money and steal wealth
from the bottom 50% of your population
can local governments print money like
no no and neither can i that's the
problem
see this would be cool if I could go to
the government say hey man I ran out of
money can can you print me some but I
can't do that so why does the local
government get to do that or the state
government or the airlines or anybody
else yeah it is like a magic trick go
ahead tell him she's a magician everyone
nobody knows this yet but she has magic
tricks so last night we were talking and
I realized that the lunch money crew
doesn't know that I'm actually a
magician explain why I do I do card
tricks she has a number of math tricks
they're not magic other math where she
like counts the cards and they can tell
you what your card is all right look at
the end of the day you're not getting a
bailout I'm not getting the bailout the
local government shouldn't get bailouts
everybody stop trying to get money
printed because you're stealing money
from the poor in order to make your
mistakes up here's the thing how much
[ __ ] do you think is going on at
local governments that they're spending
money on they should be a lot a lot
right how about at the state level I bet
you if we went and looked at a state
budget we would be appalled at the stuff
they're spending money on when I was in
college and I would report on the
University of Administration and I saw
how much stuff was going on there I was
like can you imagine what that's like on
the statement like what were they doing
what crazy stuff no just like things
that were inefficient or misleading or
whatever and we would report on it but
like I was like amazed that that was
happening at a college campus which is
like so tiny and small imagine on the
state level of them the federal level in
one of these stimulus bills there was a
one of the things that they were hung up
on and they were negotiating was how
much money was gonna be set aside for
cleaning supplies in the Capitol
building 25 million dollars I could
clean up
is sane right so listen everybody want
to bail out I'm not getting when she's
not getting one local government
shouldn't get one either
stop the madness stop the bailout
madness all right so what's going on
with Goldman Sachs Goldman Sachs thinks
that based on its models the downturn
will be four times worse than the
housing crisis and then an unprecedented
recovery Walker yeah but their whole
model is based on a double-digit drop in
GDP in q2 which I actually think is
probably pretty likely so that they're
not magicians in the sense of now look
they are probably pretty accurate in the
decline but this was cracks me up right
like oh this can be four times worse
than the worst economic crisis in our
lifetime and so if there's any recovery
of course it's gonna be unprecedented
because the drop is unprecedented right
so it's it's kind of like saying hey I
have a hundred percent growth in my
customer base if I'm a small business
you go great how many customers do you
have you said well I had one last year
and now I have two well yeah okay so I
think that part of this is just if
there's a big drop and you recover which
I think we all agree the u.s. is going
to recover it's not going to go to zero
then there will be an unprecedented
recovery but again they're basically
positioning this is it's gonna be a
pretty v-shaped recovery right this idea
that like yeah they believe it's just
everyone's gonna go home we're all gonna
sit at home and there's gonna be this
like everyone's gonna come back out
newsflash I'm willing to bet 30 to 50
percent of restaurants and small
businesses aren't coming out of this
thing
they just can't survive right and
unfortunately in many cases it's not
just a financial thing there's literally
been the breaking of the entrepreneurial
will of small businesses if you're you
know in your Middle Ages you've been
running a business for 10 or 15 years
you're like dude I hate this when I
can't get out of it I can't sell the
business I have no other job prospects
I've got employees etc here's your
chance
you should think your business is ahead
I'm gonna do something else I think it's
gonna happen all right so do you agree
with them or not they seem to be psychic
enough so and also four times worse than
the housing crisis how are they
measuring that are they saying
because they're saying that the US will
see the highest unemployment rate since
World War two according to Goldman Sachs
okay how what will call him out CNBC
what are you doing she hasn't liked your
articles alright let's move on to
tuition oh this is a this is a freaking
amazing topic so okay here's what's
interesting all these colleges you know
elite institutions like Harvard Stanford
etc have gone online if I'm a student
and I'm paying will I expect at Wishon
discount well they are expecting a
tuition discount the schools are saying
no way of course it's all sham look this
is the virus has exposed all the shams
and societies so this is interesting I
thought this was an interesting point it
says for example the average cost for an
in-person calculus one course in the
United States is twenty five hundred
dollars compared to about four hundred
dollars for the online equivalent yeah
so basically online courses are just
priced differently and some of that is
because you actually need the cost of
the electricity the building like all
that kind of stuff got it and also the
professors cost more money than at
online but if you're providing the
online experience and I paid for the
in-person experience
you shouldn't charge me for something
I'm not getting yeah I think everybody's
kind of taking the mentality of we're
all on this together like I get you're
struggling you get that I'm struggling
so people the schools aren't struggling
though these schools literally this is
the Sham of higher education they're not
schools they're asset management firms
that have schools Harvard has tens of
billions of dollars Yale tens of tons
dollar Stanford 30 billion dollars etc
here's but here's the shame I'm going to
teach you guys a real quick lesson about
higher education get billions of dollars
into an endowment manage that endowment
you have incredible tax advantages you
basically pay no taxes and you grow that
money and compound it very quickly you
then end up with tens of billions of
dollars and you claim it's for the
school and rainy days and all this stuff
but then when the rainy day comes you
don't spend the money so across a lot of
these universities what we've seen is
they've literally cut ties with their
vendors so they said hey you're the
who runs our cafeteria we're cutting our
relationship with you and then that
forces you to go fire all those
employees you got 30 billion dollars
we'll take your money and help them what
why should they suffer because you're
unwilling to spend the 30 billion
dollars by the way that's your choice
that's fine you don't want to do that
that's okay but you shouldn't get the
tax advantages from that and so what
ends up happening is we shouldn't break
up big tech we should break up the
[ __ ] universities we should take the
asset management component and get it
out of the universe' lot of hot takes
today it's because this is exposing all
of these scams that's what that is okay
why do they have to not pay taxes but I
have to pay taxes so if you were in
college right now yes and it went to
online only what would you do I probably
would just do what everyone else is
doing I'd go to the class because I have
to go to the class like like I'm already
down that path but the point is that I
think kids have a very valid argument by
the way I don't think schools are gonna
reimburse them or give them discounts or
ask tough but I think again what it's
exposing is university is not a bad
thing right but the value you get out of
going to school when you're 18 to 22
years old is more outside the classroom
size than in the classroom do you think
the consequences of the pandemic is
there gonna change education as we know
it I think that there will be changes I
just don't like there's not gonna be
like drastic changes right it's not like
hey everyone went to university and then
when we come out of the virus no one's
gonna go to college right I don't think
it's like a massive change but there's
definitely people who are sitting there
saying like wait a minute why am I
getting you know why am i paying all
this money to sit at home on zoom' I
could do this exact same thing on the
internet right or I could take online
courses or do whatever and I get the
same knowledge then it comes down like
well are you going to pay 80 grand a
year to get a certain you know one piece
of paper that's got one emblem on at
verse another some people are willing to
do that some people aren't right and
then you layer in on top of that well
it's one thing if I just had the e be
grand to pay but am I willing to go
$80,000 in debt to get that emblem on a
piece of paper it's great all right
what's going on with kwibi kwibi
apparently it did really well I'll take
Tuesday
you got red on I got hot takes are we
just on fire right now fire emoji fire
emoji
all right go oh did you hit me with the
Dikembe Mutombo so Joe Molina has a
photo with the campaign with what's
going on with so meg Whitman says that
could you reach 1.7 million downloads in
the first week so here's what I'm gonna
say this is a little bit of a misleading
number meaning lies hot tape they have a
90 day free trial until these are
charging you $4.99 or $7.99 to look at
their content well and they have 1.7
billion dollars that they've been they
literally ran Superbowl ads and on and
ran trending on Twitter before they ever
lost
so basically well how do you get users
right you can do get users through three
things you can get it through word of
mouth you can get it through earned
media and get through paid media right
and earned media basically means their
people write articles about yeah they
say god watch I earned media they also
have some a little bit of word-of-mouth
but most of their acquisition is coming
through paid acquisition their pay
because they were in a Superbowl a
that's thousands of dollars they are
they're the number one thing on Twitter
that they promoted thing so they're
spending all this money trying to get
users and for them to only get 1.7
million people is that not good look
there's plenty of people who think
that's really strong right I think
that's pathetic because when we because
again you've got to look at it as 1.7
million people are signing up for a free
service this is free that's Jim and they
got all that press coverage and they
spent millions and millions of dollars
over the last couple of months and I got
1.7 million people compare that to
Disney Disney got 10 million people in
the first day wait Disney Plus one day
it had 10 million subscribers paying no
no free trial' mad nonsense paying real
service real value real customers these
aren't real people is 1.7 million people
who are just here the tourists they're
gonna come check it out they're gonna
leave do you think that koban 19 at home
is hoping or hurting kwibi well I'm
assuming helping them one because I've
read reports that they actually have all
the content already recorded like you've
already created all the content they
have it through the rest of the year and
they sort out all their ad inventory
through the end of the year clearly for
them people are sitting at home right
now they got nothing else to do it's
like I've watched everything on Netflix
Hulu Amazon except you're I might as
well sign up for this service too and
they still only got 1.7 million people
yeah
put it this way you guys want to know a
little fact more people are gonna watch
this YouTube channel this month then
kwibi has any new users Danny was that
was but I'm just gonna put a little old
me and Polina got more people gonna
watch this YouTube channel
then quit got in the first week to sign
up we ain't got billions all we got is a
couple of jokes and a little you know
read sure yeah lunch money alright what
else is going on here JIRA we got four
minutes and 45 seconds can we get it he
really likes this who recently watched
jiro Dreams of Sushi I don't know if
you've seen this documentary it's great
what is his name Jiro Ono
alright I love movies and so does planet
even this you won't admit it of people
chasing perfection here is another one
there's a bunch of them that we've
watched we're gonna start giving you
guys heads up so there's a movie called
jiro Dreams of Sushi where is it
available where did we watch it it's on
Netflix it's called 0j iro
like it says here on the screen Dreams
of Sushi and it's about a guy who runs a
sushi shop in Japan at the basement or
the bottom floor of a subway station and
he is the only individual to run a
restaurant that what is it got three
Michelin stars and you only can sit at
the bar there's like ten seats there's
ten seats in the place it's incredibly
expensive it's like hundreds of dollars
per plate but he's been doing this he's
85 years old or 90 years old he's nine
he's 95 or 85 years old in the film in
the film
so it's definitely older and his whole
thing is perfection he's been making the
same sushi he doesn't make super exotic
stuff he makes very very basic sushi but
he tries to make it perfectly and the
documentary goes into how his sushi that
is supposed to be basic tastes different
and better excetera
and he's like look it's the way that we
treat the rice and where we get the fish
and he goes through all of the little
details so it's very very good highly
recommend also will warn you warning
warning warning if you watch the
documentary
you're gonna want sushi because it's
awesome what's your favorite kind of
sushi oh um I like spicy tuna spicy tuna
all right that's like a pretty down the
road you're a fairway you know what do
you live them I like shrimp tempura oh
yeah that's a good one all right I'm
glad we when we order you it all comes
together there's no yours in mine yeah I
go to reach for a shrimp tempura and you
don't kind of kid you were on the
playground you're probably the kid who
was like it's my ball you can't play
with us and you would go and play in the
corner and all the other kids would be
like screw her you did that you took a
ball and left mostly with you I would
for sure I would throw rocks at you on
the playground alright guys I got the
campaign matumbo here with me I
appreciate you guys watching lunch money
every day around noon oh there's the
Kimbe and polina again by the way you're
like yeah he's sober seven feet tall you
know how sure you look there well Wall
Street's rich the rest of us just trying
to get our lunch money right I
appreciate you guys watching hopefully
plaintiff will continue to join us she
may get too annoyed and leave but we'll
see she reads every single comment by
the way so if you want to leave a
comment she will read it she will
probably tell me if you're nice or not
when she has done every single day for
the last week so be nice all right any
parting words for the people
all right she's a magician we'll see you
guys tomorrow